do you envision a black panther 3 in the  next three four years or do you think  this is going to be something where the  wakanda and the characters are just sort  of embedded into the rest of the MCU  that's a great question and and to be  honest and this is not me uh this is not  me trying to not answer the question we  really want to see how audiences receive  the film you know and I think Ryan's  really interested to see how the film  plays before we decide there are  certainly ideas we've floated around of  what a a third film could be if we get  to make it but uh but until the movie  comes out we we certainly we're a bit  superstitious in that way we don't want  to count our chickens uh because you  never know what's gonna happen